good morning john so as you can tell by
the headphones the different
camera angle the length of the video
we're doing something a little bit
different today
i wanted to take an opportunity to talk
to somebody
who is a part of this community watched
her first vlogbrothers video in 2007 and
also was just a really amazing person
who does
a lot of amazing work doing advocacy and
activism and strategy
uh and writing most recently she was the
campaign manager for julian castro
she's now working with elizabeth warren
i think we're really lucky to have her
as part of this community so i wanted to
take a little bit of time to talk to
maya rupert
obviously it's a hard time so my i guess
i'll just start out by asking
um how how are you feeling right now
this is a hard time this has been
and this has been a very hard time even
as i
i feel like i have been someone i've
worked in these spaces
um a lot and i feel like i have a pretty
high capacity for
things are going badly but you know
there's there's
a light at the end of the tunnel and
that kind of thing these last couple of
weeks have hit me really hard and i know
they're hitting a lot of people really
hard and so
um you know i'm i'm hanging in i'm
taking a lot of solace in the fact that
i know
a lot of people are feeling this right
now and are making community where they
can and are being there for each other
which is always the thing that
i can take solace in these moments
because that kind of
that gives me hope that there there is
somewhere we're going to go with this
but i mean this is a tough time and this
this
one really does feel different from you
know the perspective
inside of uh you know presidential
politics at this point which is
is uh you know uh a world of its own i'm
sure
um can you give me sort of like a little
bit of a feeling for what it looks like
from that perspective a lot of leaders
right now are
looking to you know kind of what can we
put energy behind and what can
what can people sort of be doing and i
think that's that is helpful i think
that
you know people want to feel right now
like there is something to do and wait
you know ways that they can act one of
the things i'm always sort of struck by
when we talk about
you know police violence is that people
feel there's there's the hopelessness
that comes with it that i think is
understandable but then there's a
piece of hopelessness that i've never
quite been able to to square
because there's this sense of well what
can we do there's so there's only so
much that can be done
system that works like this this was
this was policy that makes it possible
for
you know police officers to act um in in
dangerous ways and not be held
accountable so there are policy
solutions to it so
that is i think that i think that's just
sometimes there's kind of a disconnect i
feel like people aren't as conscious of
that as they should be and so i'm really
heartened by all the work that people
are doing right now to point to
policy solutions that are about you know
what can what can happen
you know national use of force standards
requiring cops to de-escalate before
any kind of fatal force is used some of
these things that will have
huge huge impacts on these situations
sort of moving forward so
i think that this that we do have a
moment sort of from the
from just a political standpoint to you
know this is what we need to be calling
electives letting people know that this
is a priority
and making sure that at every level of
government local
state federal this is something that
people prioritizing we're getting folks
in office that are going to
you know take this issue seriously um
you and i are
uh about the same age so we uh you know
we're
we're we've we've lived through some
history
at this point uh and uh
but i i'm wondering how you feel about
um the
the youths right now um and and if that
is a source of any
encouragement for you right now you know
i'm i'm always
taken by uh young people and you know
how people are activating in in
these moments of crisis um i'm so
excited to see
how people are looking at this and and
demanding more
and you know i think it's it's always a
tough thing i think sort of
generationally when we're doing movement
work or in organizing i think that
there's this
you know as you just by nature of how
these things work as you get older
there are more things that you have
lived through you've seen
you've seen things work so differently
and so there is
you know you're willing to put up with
things that younger people aren't you
know and i think
one thing that i always try to encourage
people it's like as you become
sort of the older people in the movement
try to you know sort of have the
humility to recognize that
the movement is changing and as you're
the younger people in the movement have
the grace to realize that the people who
have
kind of gone through it are you know
they're they're they just had different
formative experiences so i think
i'm definitely at that point of the
movement now where i'm asking for i'm
asking for the grace and and calling on
my humility but
um but what what is what's
i think really cool about that cycle is
that it means you get to watch this new
generation of people
who look at this and say
you know this far and go further and we
are not compromising
and so i'm really excited that i'm
getting to see this generation
take this issue on because it is one
that needs
that kind of attention that kind of
demand that kind of
sort of unwillingness to compromise
right i'm i'm seeing that i'm seeing
that a lot i'm seeing that with the
folks that have taken to the streets
and it's weird because there's an
urgency to it and i really i
i have a lot of faith in this generation
of organizers
to to really make sure that as much as
this moment feels different that this
actually can be different this time so
uh you've worked inside of government a
lot and uh
and you've seen politics functioning
you've seen government functioning
there are things that are broken about
this but of course i think the uh
the the response to that can't be like
okay well let's abandon it then let's
continue to hobble it let's ignore it
let's
like it has to be fix it so how do we
fix it
i think a piece of it is um it's it's
it's people it's people getting involved
um you know it's people being involved
for the right reasons
the people right now who are having this
be one of their formative political
experiences
they are going to be qualitatively
different types of leaders because
seeing something like this and and
having that be the thing that sparks i
want to make change
so i think that you know folks that you
know if you are called to want to do
something better in a moment of crisis
like
go run do something get involved because
if that's the thing that sparks your
interest in making things better
you are one of the people we want making
things better i think beyond that
there are things about our politics that
are broken
because because there is
i mean to put simply there's a sort of a
cost to entry right i mean that
any time there is a system where if you
have resources your problems get greater
attention and if you don't have those
resources your problems get
de-prioritized
we are not have a system that is best
equipped to deal with the issues that
impact the most of us because most of us
do not
we have those kinds of resources we have
to fix
what is i think a baseline issue and
that is that our politics are way too
consumed by who can
get money into the system and therefore
have their issues looked at first
and there's obviously campaign finance
reform solutions kind of everywhere but
i think acknowledging that
is a big part of what we need to do i
also think we have to step away from
this idea that
you know i was what i was kind of saying
before that you know when we talk about
issues like racial justice that we are
talking about
sort of issues that only are relevant to
communities of color and
and as a result they can sort of be
pushed off to the side
i think that one of the tough things
about a moment like this is that
we're talking about policing but we're
also talking about a system of white
supremacy and we're talking about
you know sort of just a very fundamental
difference in the ways
that people interact in the society and
how they feel protected by the
society and it's based on race and we
have conditioned ourselves
to think of that as such a divisive
topic that we don't even want to sort of
talk about it until we're confronted
with something like this
and then we are almost surprised that we
are not super good at talking about it
we give ourselves no practice and then
biggest things happen
and people are awkward around it or
people say the wrong thing or people you
know
and and and look there are just some
people that uh
obviously there are some people who do
not care and are
are not worried that they don't know how
to what to say in this moment but i'm
not really thinking about them i'm more
thankful folks
genuinely are see a moment like this
feel the helplessness
you know white folks who maybe haven't
been as conscious of some of this stuff
and are having their eyes open
but they kind of don't know where to go
and they don't know where to start and
they don't want to say the wrong
thing so they don't say anything and
it's read differently you know so i
think
i think we've created this really weird
quagmire around the way that we
approach and talk about race that we
only talk about it in moments of crisis
when the temperatures are already so
high
and the only people that feel 100
comfortable talking about it are people
that
like study it and write about it and
talk about it and people who don't care
how they
sound talking about it and so basically
it is people who are racist or don't
care about sounding racist
talking to people who make this their
career to talk about and that
international conversation around race
and so i think some of it is almost just
letting ourselves
challenging ourselves have the awkward
conversations i think it goes back to
this question of grace i think
people can come in good faith um
and sort of get grace in return um i
think that people
i think that some of these conversations
can get a lot more
comfortable and a lot more common um it
doesn't mean they're gonna get i mean it
doesn't mean they're not gonna be
awkward because they are and they're
going to be tough and they're going to
be
courageous conversations you have to
have with people but i do think that we
have to approach it as
this is it's a necessity we can't wait
until it's
this to engage in it at all and i'm just
i'm realizing more and more how much
that still happens
you know because it is such an important
and big thing in our society i think it
is important to
be curious about it engage with it
because i think that like you can't help
if you're not
at all informed and you also can't be
like okay
the first step of me helping is to place
the burden on someone else to help
inform me
right but like you know what like you
can't
interface with anything if you don't
know about it and so i think that that
learning process is really important it
should be a bigger part of our education
system
but it should also be a part of what we
do as
as like citizens like it should be just
something that we feel
um you know is part of you know not even
necessarily just an obligation but but
something that we should be passionate
about
what you just described is i think one
of the
tensions that lies at the core of this
it's wonderful that there are people who
want
to learn and their immediate thought is
oh well i'll just
i'll ask someone because that you know
we do that with a lot of things in life
so i'll ask someone who seems to know
about this and then immediately that
that right that that puts a burden on
someone else
sometimes that is a burden that people
are willing to take on and sometimes
it's not
there's no magic ingredient as to when
that happens and so i think
a safe way to do it is you know people
always say well google and read and i
think that that's great advice and i
and i understand why that's people's
advice but i also appreciate that
it's not like this stuff is super
accessible if you
genuinely are like i need to start you
know some sort of from
from ground zero i think there are books
out there that try really really hard
um to do that there's a book called um
so you want to talk about race that i
think is incredible
and does a really good job i think from
a let's meet people where they are
standpoint but i don't think every
every book or article about racial
justice starts from a
standpoint of i mean where you are
regardless of your level
there's a disconnect there that i think
we have to acknowledge that sometimes we
are
saying we want people to learn and that
means that there are
people who are curious and don't quite
know where to go with that and so
again it's i mean i think it i think it
varies but i i
also think that you know a big way to
handle that is
having diverse friend rules because
if you hang with people
and have already have emotional ties and
a trust level and they know that your
intentions are good and you ask them
questions
people are going to be more willing to
take on that burden they're going to be
more willing to give that grace they're
going to be more
understanding of you didn't get the
vocabulary quite right but i knew where
you were going
but i think that that it's sort of it
it's kind of a chicken in the egg thing
because
yeah it is way too easy for friend
groups to
to be segregated especially for white
folk and then
for people to kind of look around and
say oh wait i don't have anyone i'm
close to i can ask about this
let me ask this random person and that's
when
and that's when there's so i mean it's
it's
it's tough but it feels like it's sort
of the the answer really does seem
to be community it's closer closer
connection because
we can do that stuff we're already in
community with each other
one one thing that we do every year here
is we have a census that we run
and uh i usually analyze
okay thank you and i usually analyze it
uh before now but haven't because
uh things got busy this year yeah we
asked a question about race in that
census i think that you were probably
aware
coming into this conversation that the
majority the audience would be
would be white folk uh so so thinking
thinking about that
like and sort of like introducing
this topic maybe to people who have been
really apprehensive about it or like you
know really like
genuinely are coming at it from a good
place but feel like
just like very anxious because like it's
a completely understandable thing to be
anxious about you know one thing that
that like i see is like
two bad reactions to the concept of
privilege
one is like i definitely don't have
privilege i have all these hard things
in my life and so that's fake
um and the second is like i have
privilege
i feel guilty about it and i will then
move through my life
with guilt but no like positive
anything on the other side of that it's
like oh so i've been given this negative
emotion
and i will just carry it around and then
do all my normal things i am
very resistant to the idea that that uh
what you have is something to
feel ashamed of because i just
i like think that we're all sort of like
in the situation that we're in
but i heard baratunde thurston say this
week in a podcast
that um it's not like everybody go like
goes around and says to superman like
stop
using your power they say use your power
for good stuff
right and uh and so that that really
resonates with me
that this is about what you have and
what you have isn't about how you should
feel about what you have it's about what
you should do with what you have
right um so with that in mind what
should we do with what we have
i really i love that framing um and i
think you're right i mean there is
there is like a knee jerk when you
recognize your heart
like a sense of like right it's like you
feel bad you feel like well then
but and and i think it's really
important to work through that because
you're right i think that the other side
of that is if i feel guilty about
something i want to hide
i don't want you or be angry or lash out
or like
shame is a terrible emotion that no one
wants to feel yeah
absolutely and so working through it and
acknowledging it and saying it out loud
and i think that that's
important you know it just it
sort of in and of itself because i think
you're right just having that shame it's
such a
that is it's so destructive but then
right there
are so many things that come from that
the
the recognition of white privilege in
these conversations means that
there are conversations that would be
easier for you to have them for me to
have
um no matter how many times like i i
talk about race a lot i write about
race a lot i tend to be a pretty
effusive friendly person i tried really
hard to say
i'm still me when i'm talking about race
but inevitably
as soon as i start talking about race
there is
there's more defensiveness that i feel
that if i were just like talking about
you know
something fun and like yeah or something
that people just want to talk to
um yeah it happens no matter and there's
and i feel like i've gotten to a point
where there's no amount of
like i want to be super accessible about
it that is going to completely relieve
that because as soon as it's coming from
me
there is an assumption of okay i've got
to say the right thing
and i don't know as much so i can't say
anything and all
and everything else that comes along
with that because of that i
pay a bigger penalty for bringing that
kind of stuff up one of the things that
white privilege is
incredibly useful at doing is is helping
to talk about some of the issues that
people of color can't bring up and so
being the one to talk about this
taking a platform that you have and
elevating
work that's being done and voices and
stories that wouldn't otherwise get that
platform
acknowledging that there are ways that
there are ways that privilege
contributed to an ability to build a
platform and therefore
will bring the next folks up that kind
of stuff is so valuable and it's so
important
and it's only going to come if people
feel comfortable saying
yes i have had privilege it is that has
helped me
i am going to make sure that i use that
and help other people
i mean i think it's a lot there's a lot
tied up with it but that this idea that
if you acknowledge privilege it means
you're somehow undermining yourself you
haven't worked hard
that it's like it's either or that it's
like you did it 1 000
by yourself or privilege is the only
reason
you are here versus here and getting to
please i feel like you had the thought
on that my thought was that
uh you're saying like if if you're
recognizing your privilege that you're
you're somehow hurting yourself you're
saying like okay i have privilege and so
i'm gonna start
succeeding less or something um
and and like that i see people who who
think that
um and but like to to me it's like
helping people is the best
part of being successful it's like being
able to like
like meet people who are amazing and be
like people should pay attention to this
great person and it's also like it's
well known psychologically that helping
other people makes you happier than
helping yourself
and so it's like like why wouldn't we do
it like we like of course our brains
don't think that
but like that's how we react you know
it's there's this
fairly famous study that like if you
give somebody um
50 bucks and you say spend it on
yourself
or you say spend it on someone else that
at the end of the day
like they would all prefer to spend it
on themselves but at the end of the day
they're happier when they spend it on
someone else
right and um and so like being being
mindful and aware of that
and and like and also like having had
that experience a number of times
i know i know it is true um even if it
doesn't feel intuitive all the time
so so to me it's like oh like this is so
wonderful that like i have an
opportunity to use a power that i have
because really what privilege is is its
power you know
should be thinking more about that how
to use that because like it makes me
happier and it makes the world better
and like
those are the two things i want
they're just that even clear i mean
it's true and i also think i mean you
know i i think it's important to
acknowledge that
people who don't have privilege in some
ways have privilege in other places
right
yeah i have an awful lot of privilege as
a straight cis
person right like i that that is that
and and we have the sense of you're
either privileged or you're not like
they're
it's binary right and so in different
settings
i'm the one who can say wait a minute
there's something i can bring up here
that like my queer friends couldn't or i
i can be the one to call out
ableism because as an able-bodied person
it's easier for me right so
i think that that acknowledging that
around race conversations
yes i i'm gonna rely a lot more on
my friends who my white friends who want
to act in our ship
and and bring this stuff up when i can
but there are going to be rooms where i
absolutely have that ability to do it
and so
i also think that helps us sometimes
because again if we conceptualize it as
you have it or you don't that makes it
way too easy to buy into this model
of somehow it makes me less than or
you know that it really is situational
and like i think it's important that we
talk about it my last question here for
you is uh what's making you hopeful
right now
i will say again you know watching the
young people who are
are leading this fight um is is
incredibly incredibly inspiring
um it makes me feel like you know there
are people who
are seeing this and are having that
spark awakened in them
and so you know you know this becomes
sort of the
issue that our movement is taking up
that leaders are taking up like i i
think that that's
that is going to be huge i am seeing
more of these conversations you know
i've gotten a lot of people who've
reached out to me
um in you know in these moments who i
you know these are our friends that i
have i have strong relationships with
who have
texted and done that you know i want to
check in how are you feeling but have
gone further than that and said you know
i'm raising kids and i don't know how i
should be talking about this but i know
that i
i haven't talked to my white kids about
this and i know that
peers who have black kids are already
having to have these conversations so
you know what do you think what should i
be doing what should i be saying and
i'm i'm so grateful that it's like okay
people
i mean people want to do this i i think
that there
is there's so much power in just being
willing to say
huh i haven't thought about that before
and like there's again there's
vulnerability there
because there's the obvious part of like
well how lucky am i that i never had to
think about it and you could get stuck
in that but instead people are actually
reaching out and trying to do something
different
i'm seeing a lot more of the facebook
posts where people and
and my absolute absolute favorite thing
is for people when they say like hey
listen if
if you're having this moment right now
and you're hearing people say black
lives matter and you
think to yourself well all lives matter
dm me
one of the i think hardest things about
yeah yeah that's great it's it's
and it's so critical because here's the
thing you get on social media and you're
like
if you're thinking this unfollow me if
you're thinking this
i'm gonna say you know you're gonna get
a lot more likes and engagement and
there's something really satisfying
about
just unfollowing the family member who
always says the wrong thing or who you
know like
there's you get satisfaction from that
and
you get external validation from it but
the actual
helpful conversation is one that you can
only have indeed
because it's the conversation where you
say you know what actually
i used to think this or i've actually
had to like i've had moments like this
and you make yourself vulnerable so this
person makes themselves vulnerable back
and you can actually get to somebody in
a way you couldn't if you yeah
nobody's changing your mind based on an
argument on someone's timeline on
facebook
right publicly performatively so that
everybody's looking at it and you can't
show any weakness yeah
exactly right it undermines every single
thing
that would be valuable about this
conversation you can't admit
huh i hadn't considered that like you
can't do that you can over dm you can
over phone calls and so that i think is
so much of what we say when when when
there's a sense of like go get your
people
like the the goal there is not go
excoriate on
social media your people the idea museum
i and i think look again i do i it's it
i get it
even from a standpoint that has nothing
to do with external validation it feels
good to have somebody
say something awful and you to slam the
door in their face there's something
satisfying about that
but it's not helpful and i think that's
one of the tough things to remember
about being
an ally is that on some level it sucks
like it's not supposed to be easy it's
doing a lot of the hard work it feels
good because you know you're doing the
right thing not because in a moment it's
satisfying it
you're actually supposed to do the stuff
that makes you a little uncomfortable
and that gives an inch and lets that
person come in enough
and then say look i get it and here's
how i got here
that's the conversation that stays with
them and so i'm really i've been
really really excited every time i see
that kind of stuff because i know that
the real work
has to happen behind the closed doors
and it doesn't get the likes and it
doesn't get the retweets
but it actually might be the thing that
stops someone from saying it the next
time
or that has someone think twice the next
time they're
in a situation well uh this has been a
really wonderful conversation i
appreciate you doing it also thanks for
chatting with me offline a bit this
morning
um so it's great to talk with you uh
what was your first vlog brothers video
i saw that harry potter
deathly hallows wow yes wow
so yes he's been a nerd the whole time i
see what i really have been
it was funny too because i remember i
saw it because it was it was it was
featured on youtube's
like home page i was not like a youtuber
i did not know about this whole
community i saw this i was like it was
2007.
no one did thank you thank you for that
because
we're going to now pretend like i
definitely know so much about it
now you're really in no i'm like i don't
in it
no but i remember it was there and i
like send it to my sister and then i
just saw that like you guys were doing
this thing and i have a
sister i'm very close to and so i'm
always really excited when siblings are
doing stuff together
i remember just going back and just i
was so and have remained and this
very genuinely true i have remained so
impressed by this community that has
been built because so much of i think
what we were just talking about is
people seeking out community and trying
to have some grace and trying to have
some humility
is not always that doesn't always have a
very natural
home online um and i really i really saw
it here you know like i
i don't myself sort of make videos or
anything but i remember there was a
period of time where people would
make their own videos and share them and
i felt this very
like you all had cultivated and brought
together a group of people who
genuinely seem to want to just do good
things together
and i've loved that i loved the idea of
the projects and like there's a charity
now because people
you know what i mean like that was so
i was i've just been so consistently
warmed by that and have always just been
a big fan so
i'm so grateful that you that you reach
out and i'm so happy we don't have this
conversation
oh thank you so much uh and i'm so
grateful that you're doing all of the
work you're doing i'm grateful you're a
part of this community
but uh also other communities and all
the stuff you're doing
to help uh to help make the world a bit
of a better place
um where can people find you i'm on
twitter i'm
um i don't know
maya rupert on twitter i think i'm the
same on facebook
so you're not obviously you're not on
tick tock yet i i had interns teach me
tick tock i did i
wish we had saved the out tanks because
it was me just consistently not
understanding the vehicle at all
oh my god yeah this is i i feel like
my social media is limited but i often
and yeah on twitter well thank you so
much maya
john i'll see you on tuesday
[Laughter]
that was awesome if you want to check
out so you want to talk about race the
book she was talking about that's linked
in the description
also eight can't wait dot org the number
eight
can't wait.org it's a fantastic resource
makes it easy to understand
how to start or continue work and
advocacy trying to
get some things changed